so recently i got to sit down with a
six-time olympic medalist and one of the
best skiers of all time this fella won a
gold medal in 2010 in vancouver and he
just took the bronze in sochi for super
g the super g
and upon sitting down with him i found
out he's also super chill let's take a
look at my meeting with bodie miller
i am honestly thrilled to be sitting
down with one of the most legendary
skiers of all time bodie miller thanks
for taking the time absolutely thanks
for being here bode
the bowed man so that's a pretty unusual
name
miller
did they name you bodhi for the bodhi
tree under which buddha sat and achieved
nirvana
you know it's not spelled the same so
you'd have to assume not but they're the
kind of people who and i actually tried
the same thing they didn't think of
naming me before i was born or they had
a name picked out before i was born but
then
once i was born is when they kind of
decided that i would sort of
tell them
what name i thought i was gonna yeah so
they were right in the zone and i was
born with my eyes open almost home birth
so my dad was the one who was there sort
of delivering me and he said my eyes
were open looking right at him which
just totally freaked him out wow and
that's when he kind of came to him you
seem pretty relaxed i am pretty relaxed
you seem pretty chill
pretty down to earth
but then you hit those slopes and you
become a monster
do you get into a meditative place when
your mind is clear and you're just on
the mountain sometimes it changes i mean
obviously sometimes you have days where
you're a basket case and you can't get
your head in the right place right for
me i tend to i tend to get myself in
into the right mood
pre you know beforehand and then kind of
tip it up as it goes
a little zippy said
no
unfortunately ski racing isn't one of
those things where you can take the edge
off but in europe it's uh it's very
common i mean they have those little
schnapp stations down the mountain and
everybody drinks and has you know stops
there's schnapp stations yeah that's a
little huts that they stop at on the way
down the mountain and they do it all day
and by the end of the day they're
absolutely hammered and still ripping
around skiing and you can see
the level of skiing is significantly
higher mid-morning in europe if you go
onto a mountain than it is
mid-afternoon have you been swearing in
your other interviews
yeah i can't help it really i think
there's certain ideas and certain gaps
of expression that you just can't get
around balls
if you do it
now you there you go no i said it's
expression i don't just do them there's
no flagrance in this in this side of the
room i have to give you
something to say you have to lead me i
understand that you can't watch football
right now
i read that you're not in this to win
medals necessarily it's just to ski as
fast as humanly possible
no i changed my mind today really for
the metals now i switched it up yeah
well now that i have metals too so i can
always just pull those out and be like
suck it cling clank clean clay yeah is
that how you call your family to suffer
the champ is eating
i've never seen them actually from when
i first won them i don't know where they
go they i they go somewhere i'm assuming
my mom maybe has them or somebody has no
way i've never seen them again since
then so if you left them in your hippie
house your dad has melted them down as
some sort of pagan ritual or skipped
them on the lake yeah have you ever
taken mushrooms
nope
not that i will admit to
i've also never taken mushrooms don't
you find them to be consciousness
expanding
nope
yeah do your parents take mushrooms
no
your wife is a professional beach
volleyball player
nice you bring her into the mountains of
mordor
and when she's working you just get to
work on your awesome tampon lay on the
beach and watch
the amazon women jump around and spike
the volleyball can the other people see
the women or are you tripping balls
they're there and here they are
thanks for teaching us how to open our
heart chakras and get in touch with the
universal consciousness absolutely
namaste
we went low that time
i think it's totally great that he never
took mushrooms
you